i grew up an orthodox jew and i'm still
i'm still quite observant but not fully
orthodox
and i of course kept kosher
uh in
for all of my youth
then when i was in england
uh in for my junior year i figured it
wouldn't hurt my parents feelings and i
violated every ritual law in judaism
because i didn't want to observe out of
habit but out of conviction
and then i came back to many of them so
that for much of that year i didn't keep
kosher at all
and i remember this is what i i want to
tell you what this has to do with your
question
so i i remember the first time i ate ham
and it was it was a somewhat emotionally
jolting experience
now
fast forward
i also remember the first time i voted
republican
i want you to know
that that was tougher emotionally
than the first time i ate ham
i thought i was betraying everything
good that i had ever learned
i had gone over to the dark side
by voting republican that is how deep
the belief in liberals forget leftists
is
that as bad as the left is i can't vote
republican
what does that tell you about just human
nature in terms of belief because i've
definitely come around to this that that
my atheist friends some of whom are your
friends too
uh that they end up believing in
something one way or another i think
that's in essence what you're saying you
can trade all that stuff in for another
set of views but you're going to end up
believing in that and usually it's kind
of worse
the uh the brilliant line on that is is
attributed to g k chesterton but i don't
know if there's proof he actually said
it but the guy was so witty he might
have said it and here it is when people
stop believing in god
they don't believe in nothing
they believe in anything
and here's your proof
they believe men give birth
okay
that's the proof of chesterton's line
they don't believe in nothing they
believe in anything
if you're a college graduate today you
not only believe men give birth you
believe that to deny men give birth
is to deny science
you by the way said in essence that on
bill maher you know what basically about
a year ago and the media two years ago
two years two and a half years ago was
it that night before
what what a time warp
so
i i it you could you're you you've seen
it but your uh viewers can watch this
it's somewhere on youtube dennis prager
bill maher yeah we'll lay it in
we'll lay the clip in right here so
people get to see it
the left wing says i'll give you
gigantic lies that the united states is
a racist country
this this is a lie this is a gargantuan
lie this is the least racist
multi-cultural multi-ethnic country in
the history of the world that these
people believe it is proof to me about
how effective lying
this is an unbelievably non-racist
country have you people been to asia
do you people know that the japanese did
not allow one vietnamese boat person
into japan okay because they're not
japanese but we allowed them into
america what is that
no we're better than the japanese we're
better than everyone dumb argument we
are less racist than any country with
many races okay
it is a lie but we could still have
documented of course there's i'm a jew
okay there are anti-semites in america
it is a giant lie that america is
anti-semitic i taught jewish history at
brooklyn college i know it i wrote two
books on judaism this is the least
anti-semitic country jews have ever
lived in to say america's anti-semitic
is a lie to say it is racist is a lie
okay these are giant left-wing lies
we're talking about degrees to say that
men can menstruate is a lie and that is
now that is what it said
wait wait wait wait where did that i
never said you've never heard it right
okay check it out folks check it out i
think anyone who says
not menstruate what's considered
transphobic i i miss this whole story
he said oh trump lies trump lies trump
lies said doesn't compare the left lies
what are you talking about dennis well
america's
systemically racist is a gigantic lie
and so is men menstruate
and he just laughed and the audience was
laughing all at me
where the hell did i come up with that
goofy line men menstruate that was just
two and a half years ago
and now he's making fun of the emoji
from apple of the of the uh of the was
it the pregnant man the pregnant man
yeah so what yeah so actually help me as
my as my uh proxy rabbi
one of the things i've been talking
about on the show a lot for the last two
months maybe more than anything else is
my last remaining liberal friends so the
bill maher types who get it on free
speech and they get it on wokism and
they get it on critical race theory and
all the stuff but they seem unable to
get to the end of the road which is that
perhaps
liberalism in its modern sense or the
democratic party in its modern sense or
some version of those things is what led
to all of this and they might have to
vote for you scary religious republicans
what do i do with these people i want to
be
but i also want to get them to the end
of it okay
you are so right so here is my story and
this will answer
your question thank you thank you
for solving this one for me yep yep no
but it's not gonna you're not gonna be
happy here here it is
so i grew up an orthodox jew and i'm
still i'm still quite observant but not
fully orthodox
and i of course kept kosher
uh in
for all of my youth
then when i was in england uh in for my
junior year i figured it wouldn't hurt
my parents feelings and i violated every
ritual law in judaism because i didn't
want to observe out of habit but out of
conviction
and then i came back to many of them so
that for much of that year i didn't keep
kosher at all
and i remember this is what i i want to
tell you what this has to do with your
question
so i i remember the first time i ate ham
and it was it was a somewhat emotionally
jolting experience
now
fast forward
i also remember the first time i voted
republican
i want you to know
that that was tougher emotionally
than the first time i ate ham
i thought i was betraying everything
good that i had ever learned
i had gone over to the dark side
by voting republican that is how deep
the belief in liberals forget leftists
is
that as bad as the left is i can't vote
republican
the the
toxicity of the message
that the danger is on the right
has been so effective
that bill maher could never vote
republican
i look you may be right and you're
probably more of a realist then maybe
i'm still a little bit of a dreamer but
i'm going to work hard on getting the
guy to move oh i i don't know we have to
work he who saves one life is considered
to have saved the whole world by the way
my friend i don't know if you've ever
seen any of these videos on prageru but
there was a guy
very handsome guy by the way who did a
video that was all about people
leaving the political closet you might
find that one interesting very handsome
guy beard i don't remember him
interesting i i i it's funny i i we have
some handsome presenters
anyway you could go we'll we'll send you
the whole catalog you'll dig it um all
right i want to talk about covet a
little bit because i went with you in
october
of 2020 a month before the election
i said to you dennis you gotta come with
me to one of these trump rallies in
beverly hills i had gone the week before
by accident i had driven past one after
breakfast and i said i'm just going to
walk in there and see what happens it
was the most joyous spectacular thing i
had ever seen at a political
in from a political perspective at least
and i and i called you the next day i
said dennis you got to come to this
thing we go to this thing this is that
you know still at the peak of covert or
whatever you want to call it there's
thousands of people
smiling happy dancing singing joyous and
as we're walking to uh santa monica
boulevard we had to park a couple blocks
away you said to me and neither one of
us were vast you said to me you know
what it would probably be good if i got
kovit here that's what you said
uh you then did get coveted about a year
later and were
attacked in the most
vile ways on twitter and everywhere else
for getting coveted while not vaxxed
i think you see where i'm going with
this can you just lay out what your
story was on all of this and i also want
to give you credit actually i'm doing
too much talking as the interviewer but
i'll give you i want to give you credit
on something uh you said back in april
of 2020 which is now almost two years
ago your exact quote related to
lockdowns
quote the worldwide lockdowns are the
greatest mistake in human history
that's what you said basically two years
ago about all this nonsense then we walk
into a rally
and you were prepared to get covered you
didn't get it there he ended up getting
it about a year later
longest question i've ever set up take
it away
no i i now
don't in any way be apologetic i i love
listening to you anyway but
okay there are two separate issues
they're related uh one is what i i'm
very proud of the fact
because it took i have to admit but you
you you're courageous yourself so you
know this
and that's the greatest compliment i
could offer you're all so handsome i was
kidding about the
good too i video know i don't know
you lost a little weight you look good
i look good i don't know if i lost
weight okay thank you
uh by the way i hate being told i look
good because i heard many years ago this
great line there are three ages in life
youth
middle age and you're looking great
so every time somebody says i'm looking
good or looking great i go oh crap
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell